of all joe biden's pledges during his
first hundred days
it has promised to tackle global tax
avoidance which could have the biggest
long-term impact
it's not right we're going to reform
corporate taxes
so they pay their fair share but this
irish-american president's plans are
likely to face the toughest resistance
here in dublin the celtic tiger has
built much of its economy on attracting
foreign businesses to set up shop here
and that was partly down to its very low
twelve and a half percent corporate tax
rate
i'm proud of the part that it has played
in our economic development
uh uh that for a a country of our scale
and size
uh that we were um able to grow our
economy we do have really significant
reservations
regarding a global minimum effective tax
rate that is at such a level
that it means only certain countries and
certain size economies can benefit from
that race
we have a really significant concern
about that
why does this matter well since 2000
corporate tax rates in most countries
have been heading down
look at ireland right at the bottom with
its 12 and a half percent rate
the u.s and uk plan to increase their
rates in the coming years but joe
biden's
also proposing that all countries should
agree to a global minimum rate which he
first put at 21
and is now cut to 15 a couple of days
after this interview was recorded
but even at this level you can see one
country which would still be below that
minimum
ireland so his position on this is
crucial
and in his strongest message for the u.s
president yet the finance minister says
he's not budging do you envisage in you
know five years time 10 years time
there'll still be an irish 12 and a half
percent
corporate tax rate yes i do i do
anticipate
that there will continue to be a place
for a rate such as this and for low
rates
now this issue has been under discussion
in technical circles for some time but
here's why it's no longer
academic next week finance ministers
from around the world including pascal
donahoe
you just heard from including janet
yellen from the u.s will be meeting
here in london in that building and this
issue
is likely to come up in other words
these reforms the biggest reforms may be
to global corporate taxation
in a century could be about to become
very real indeed
so why now for tax experts the real
question is
why has it taken so long i think the
reason we're here now is really
a concern about profit shifting and tax
avoidance by big multinational companies
the tax system as it is is completely
broken it was set up in the 1920s for a
completely different world
britain's chancellor rishi sunak is
understood to support a global minimum
tax rate
but only provided the u.s also agrees to
other reforms on how tax is calculated
which would ensure the tech giants
paying more
but for ireland which has enjoyed many
years of economic growth boosted by
foreign investment
the coming months of diplomacy could be
testing
ed conway sky news